all right yuma arizona mayor declaring a
local emergency as overwhelmed and
understaffed border agents are
scrambling to apprehend hundreds of
illegal immigrants
that extreme level of proclamation
really opens doors it created a large
backup then
caused the spillout
into the community and really the
differences between now and when we've
had releases into the community before
is that these individuals have not been
through the process of border patrol
joining us live ranking member of the
house subcommittee on workforce
protections congressman fred keller
congressman great to see as always at
this point is joe biden simply ignoring
this crisis
almost willfully at this point
uh the crisis is the border um yeah it
appears that way and the vice president
uh
supposedly was getting to the root cause
and there's myself and about a hundred
of my colleagues on the republican side
did something they didn't do and that
was visit the southern border the ports
of entry the intake facilities and talk
to the border agents and the family the
american families that are living on
this side of the border dealing with the
crisis they've created
let's talk specifically about the about
yuma arizona because these numbers are
wild in october 2020 there were 787
encounters with illegal immigrants look
at uh 2021 october over 21 thousand
do you know why there has been such a
spike
in encounters in the yuma county arizona
area usually when we think of
illegal immigrant border crossings at a
high capacity we think texas but now
this arizona has become sort of ground
zero zero for this behavior
i i think they're they're going to
wherever they think they can get across
the border and and texas is doing some
things the state itself is doing some
things not necessarily the
administration
and
one thing that i learned right at the
border is that
the cartels have more control over the
border than the president is allowing
our border patrol agents to exercise and
the trump policies were working to
remain in mexico
you know the
just take a look at building the wall
those things work
and the biden administration has
reversed all that and gone back to catch
and release and
now we have the danger of people that
have been on the terror watch list that
have been caught crossing the border and
what's more concerning about the ones
we're catching is the people that are
not being caught that become could be
coming in the united states yeah you
know congressman real quick because you
said the biden administration went back
to catch and release they did have to
reimplement the remain in mexico policy
but the thing that i found interesting
about that is that it's only at uh
rolling out in seven entry points which
means
if i'm understanding this correctly that
an illegal immigrant if they go to the
eighth um checkpoint that isn't on the
remaining mexico list
it is catch and release once again
yes it is
they need to get back to the policies
that were proven that work
and that is to remain in mexico and
apply it equally across the entire
border across every encounter they also
need to look at finishing the wall and
enforcing our nation's laws the laws
which they took in us uphold congressman
quickly on this final topic the entire
house republican conference uniting
behind your resolution to eliminate joe
biden's vaccine mandate for businesses
the numbers and the politics say you
lose this you say the message of your
resolution could overcome all that why
well because we're seeing democrat
governors in some states support this
i've had conversations with my democrat
colleagues on the other side of the
allies we're getting more support
and they're hearing the same things that
i'm hearing from people all across
pennsylvania's 12th congressional
districts things my republican
colleagues are hearing that this mandate
is really going to create more of a
problem to the people who created the
greatest economy in the world and got us
through this pandemic and that's the
people that go to work every day 80
million americans are going to be
impacted by this and they shouldn't be
forced to decide whether they can
provide for their families
and
work versus get the other testing so
this is really a thing of whether we
stand with the american people the
people for whom we work or we stand for
for
a mandate put in by this president
congressman fred keller thank you so
much for joining us
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now